[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je peux me tromper
[Musique]
on
merci ça sonne bien la science vous
trouvez pas c'est certainement pas le
premier commentaire que vous vous êtes
dit et c'est tout à fait normal la
science et la musique c'est très rare
qu'on peut faire le lien entre les deux
domaines
on a souvent l'impression que c'est
complètement à l'opposé dans notre
société
pourtant nous c'est deux choses qui nous
habite et qui nous passionne là autant
que l'autre
comme le dit denis françois l'histoire
en fait c'est qu'on étudie dans un
programme double et la très grande
majorité du temps quand on parle de nos
programmes aux gens on se répondent par
des gens qui se grattent la tête par des
gens qui nous trouve bizarre d'aimer les
deux frères qui sont le si éloigné que
ça donne lieu parfois les petites
situations un peu cocasse par exemple
quand promène avec notre gros manuels de
biologie dans le département de musique
on se fait devancer les petits regards
en coin
qu'est-ce qu'ils font leur double file à
bidart c'est le fun parce qu'on peut la
déplacer mais dans le département des
sciences on a de l'air fou un peu avec
un qui inquiète donc à force de se faire
poser ces questions-là d'avoir ces
regards là qui sont dirigés vers nous
nous on s'est demandé pourquoi les liens
entre la science et la musique pourrait
pas être plus clair parce que on sait
qui en a mais on voulait le montrer aux
gens que l'on n'ait pas fourni que
blizzard d'aimer les deux sphères alors
à limited énergie là on était tellement
convaincus qu'on est allés parler nos
profs de sciences on est allé parler à
nos profs de musique qui on eu lieu on a
recherché et on est arrivé à un constat
très intéressant et si la musique
c'était le pont entre le monde des arts
et le monde des sciences
en fait la musique existe depuis
extrêmement longtemps le premier
instrument remonte à l'arc musique à la
préhistoire
mais c'est depuis relativement récemment
que c'est la science qui a permis de
comprendre tous les phénomènes impliqué
pour que vous puissiez entendre la belle
musique
une fois que la science a compris cette
musique le elle a pu devenir un outil
dans cette méfiance et dans notre vie de
tous les jours mais pour bien comprendre
de quoi on vous parle de musées que
plein de choses qu'en termes on va
commencer par se mettre à niveau
il faut faut dire que la musique c'est
un regroupement de sont donc c'est
plusieurs sont laissons ça marche quand
on parle à des mathématiciens ou un
déficit
mais quand on parle à des gens et
surtout les musiciens on parle de notes
alors à sa plus simple expression
allons-y avec une note et pas n'importe
lequel j'ai nommé du style du staff
c'est pas un autre comme les autres
puisque il part en voyage
il part de la guitare il sera dans votre
sourire en plusieurs étapes faciles donc
hommes savent on sort d'un petit peu
plus près cela on se rappelle à toutes
les poussées de la musique c'est pas de
la science en fait c'est lui découvrir
bon juste avant les points voyagera
comme les autres gustave ils voyagent
pas un avion ça lui prend un milieu pour
se propager par définition un son pour
ce qu'ils savaient pas on parle d'une
perturbation dans un milieu donc peu à
la manière d'une goutte d'eau dans un
étang calme qui dit perturbations dans
un milieu du milieu et donc s'il n'ya
pas de milieu ben il peut pas avoir deux
guitares qui se propage donc dans le
vide
on entend les explosions de star wars
dans l'espace c'est pas vrai ça prend un
milieu que ce soit un solide que ce soit
de l'eau que ce soit de l'air
ça prend un milieu pour gaza se propage
maintenant sa version d'un petit peu
plus près bon je veux dire des gros mots
scientifiques stress et passer pour des
complices
comment ça fonctionne je vous parlais de
perturbations donc à l'origine de son ca
prend quelque chose qui vibre que ce
soit mes cordes vocales que ce soit la
corde de ma guitare que ce soit la
membrane haut parleurs ça prend quelque
chose qui vivre qui vous ferait aussi
les molécules du million en question bon
dont tu vas avoir des variations de
pression donc ça va super comprimé
auront une zone de compression et une
zone de décompression et ainsi de suite
ça va se déplacer de manière
longitudinale jusqu'à votre rêve finis
les grands thèmes scientifiques il ya
quatre paramètres qui vont influencer le
voyage de notre ami gustave premièrement
sa hauteur vont être déterminée par la
quantité de ciation qui va voir ce mot
sur vos tympans en une seconde
on peut parler de longueur d'onde ou de
hertz dans le monde des sciences 1 hertz
égale une oscillation sur notre teint
pas par seconde donc par exemple donc
quelque chose autrement dit cécile et
notre voix aiguë ou grave si je vous
joue des notes aigües sur le piano ça
sonne comme ça
la note la plus aiguë du piano et à 4186
certes donc il ya des variations de
pression 4186 fois sur vos dépends en
une seule seconde
et si je vous jure des notes très grave
c'est nul à caen ce grave
27 vibrations sont repeints par seconde
le deuxième paramètre qui m'influence et
le voyage de notre ami gustave c'est son
intensité donc c'est la fièvre
simplement pratiquement la force avec
lesquels ça va vibrer sur votre banc on
dire on en parle en décibels
oui c'est tout simplement le volume donc
si je vous dit quelque chose de pas très
fort
[Musique]
au contraire s'ils ont vu quelque chose
de plus fort
paramètres mais retrouve la durée
combien de temps est-ce que ça va vibrer
sur votre paiement
et quatrièmement et non le moindre même
si les trois premiers paramètres sont
respectées ce qui fait que votre oreille
peut reconnaître le la de ma guitare
si bien là de mon piano
c'est que très longue histoire très
courte qu'un sont réguliers sont votre
père quand on parle de son pur mais par
contre les astros en musique donne des
sons complexes qu'une addition de son
pur vous avez peut-être déjà entendu le
mot harmonique
c'est sur ces questions un instrument
s'est faite de matériel s'est fait dans
une forme particulier et c'est deux
choses vont influencer qu'elle
harmonique va être mis de l'avant et
qu'elles sont vous allez entendre sur
votre sort vous le connaît par coeur et
c'est ce qui fait que vous allez
reconnaître eux sont donnés ce soir par
rapport à nous c'est la régularité des
coûts qui va avoir sur votre oreiller
dépendamment de sa conformation donc
juste avant tout retrouver gustave et
passe par tous ces paramètres là et on
est capable de le capter avec des
capteurs à son qui sont tous intégrés à
l'intérieur de nous nos oreilles
c'est très bien fait des oreilles et
c'est très précis pour vous donner un
exemple notre teint pas va percevoir une
perturbation qui est 10 millions de fois
plus petit que la pression atmosphérique
terrestre convient à tous les jours donc
c'est très très bien faire les oreilles
et une fois que le tympan ne tint pas
aperçu ces perturbations là elle se
range à la cochlée la cochlée c'est un
petit organe dans votre oreille qui est
remplie d'un liquide aqueux et qui
tapissaient de cellules ciliées
et c'est là que ça commence à permettre
d'analyser le sont dans le fond les
cellules ciliées
elle capte le son et c'est là qu'on peut
savoir leurs auteurs donc si il y à des
notes et du
ça va être laissé le soulier en haut de
votre corps clés qui vont réagir s'il ya
des notes moyennes
ça va être celle dans la moyenne et sans
surprise s'il ya des notes graves savent
être celles qui sont plus en jambes donc
une fois que les cellules ciliées ont pu
analyser ces sont là elles peuvent les
transformer en influx nerveux et c'est
cet influx nerveux là qui permet au
cerveau de comprendre la musique qu'on
entend donc leur faire comprendre que
les sons qui sont des ondes mécaniques
et cela devient des influx nerveux et
peuvent revenir à notre cerveau et créer
des réactions chez nous et créer des
comportements donc c'est ça qui est
incroyable avec ça c'est que sa part
d'un objet sapeurs de cordes vibrantes
et c'est de l'air qui se déplace donc
c'est vraiment impressionnant et on va
vous donner un exemple si on joue
quelque chose aux mineurs vous allez
toujours ressentir une émotion un peu
plus allez savoir que c'est une mineure
au contraire si on vous jure quelque
chose de majeur vous aller tout de suite
voir le contraste entre les deux
émotions que ça reflète donc ce qui se
passe dans votre cerveau lorsque vous
écoutez de la musique c'est incroyable
ça crée un feu d'artifice les influx
nerveux entre dans votre cerveau se
promène partout dans toutes les zones
cérébrales et sans influence beaucoup
beaucoup et tout ce qui se passe dans
vos travaux il ya beaucoup
d'informations qui se promènent en même
temps et ça ça peut être visible
physiquement parce que le corps calleux
qui est la seule chose qui retient qui
relie les deux émissaires de notre
cerveau va se densifier parce qu'il ya
tellement d'informations qui passe
dedans parce que ça se promène d'un côté
l'eau dans l'avant en arrière qu'il
devient plus dense et qu' il est visé
bleus visuellement sur l'escale
lorsqu'on regarde le cerveau de
musiciens ou de personne qui écoute
beaucoup de musique c'est c'est à ce
point fort la musique c'est des zones
qui viennent modifier physiquement votre
cerveau alors tous les processus
convient de vous décrire ça se déroule
environ 3 centièmes de seconde gustave
se déplace dans l'air grosso modo 300 km
seconde et un influx nerveux peut
parcourir dans votre cerveau à une
vitesse dans jusqu'à 100 mètres seconde
donc c'est fou comment tout se déroule
vite et c'est tout ce que ça prend pour
que vous puissiez apprécier la musique
que vous aimez
donc ça a pris beaucoup de scientifiques
pour comprendre ce qu'ils pouvoir
remettre en lumière c'était quoi la
musique de fond donc c'est la science
qui ont compris la musique
regarde ça d'un petit peu plus près le
tout premier scientifique que milly
balbutiements qui a regardé son
instrument d'un et scientifique qui sait
pythagore celui qu'on a tous détestés en
secondaire 2 pour ces triangles
rectangles
mais pas je suis fait des trucs plate a
étudié il a fait des trucs très géniale
pythagore ce qu'il faut avec lui c'est
que ces travaux sont l'origine même de
tout un pan de la physique aujourd'hui
qui s'appelle l'acoustique s'intéresse
aux ondes sonores
ça aura plus sensibles c'est grâce à la
musique est un historien musique que
l'acoustique aujourd'hui ni le principal
problème auquel il s'est buté sait
comment est-ce qu'on peut accorder un
instrument notre fixe comme une guitare
ou au piano toujours la même manière
parce que la voix on peut chanter les
nôtres qu'on veut mais qu'arrive un
instrument mais il faut arriver à la
corde et toujours de manière juste donc
calculer ce que vérifier c'est par
rapport à des cordes de même tension et
de même matériel quelle longueur ça
prend pour avoir des sons qui sonne bien
ils sont bien accordés dont qui a fait
beaucoup de matches et il ya au calcul
est ce qu'on appelle la catégorie c qui
a été génial et qui a permis et pendant
plus d'un millénaire en fait à des
musiciens de jouer de la musique était
très fantastique
le problème avec la capitale russe et
qui permettait pas avec un seul
instrument de faire une modulation donc
en français de penser par exemple une
don majeur et en ré majeur donc ça prend
une dispute à gori sienne pour joindre
une beaujoire et une conjointe amis donc
dans la pièce quand vous jouez au début
la réplique à piano et 4 guitare pour
jouer cette scène dans l'admin c'est un
petit peu exagéré
deuxième raison du distributeur en mai
mais sa super bien fonctionné pendant un
millénaire parce que la musique était
pas évolué comme on la connaît
aujourd'hui est polyphonique au cours du
16e siècle est arrivé un très grand une
révolution dans le monde de la musique
il ya les tierces et les six qui ont été
acceptés bon pour votre argent
ils vont vendre un tiers
une section
ce qu'il faut avec ça dans les calculs
pythagoriciens matière s'était pas tout
à fait des calculs et qui est un peu
fausse fait qu'elle était déterminée
comme son dissonant fait c'est juste
plus tard en fait qu'ils ont compris
qu'ils avaient mal calculé puisque pour
sa quinte edison donc quand ils ont
déterminé que c'était consona ils ont il
a fallu refaire le système ait eu
plusieurs systèmes proposés lui qui nous
intéresse il appelle système de charline
au bord du défaut aux armes hinault et
il était génial permis de moduler avec
un seul instrument donc ça prenait +3
piano pour faire trop modulation trop
tonalité différente
le problème c'est qu'un instrument qui
découlait d'autres sources est l'archi
cembalo est divisée l'octave donc la
distance entre d'eau et un dos plus
aiguë en 36 ou division donc pour faire
la comparaison le piano ici l'octave est
divisée en 12 touches et ça donne 80
avait touché en tout donc c'est très
raisonnable
le piano de terminaux avec ses 36
touches par acteurs auraient eu besoin
de 263 touche pour un instrument donc
c'est assez gros et compliqué à gérer
on pouvait faire mieux que ça donc la
palme revient à un mathématicien belge
du nom de simmons tv lui est allé avec
la pratique
et puisque les mathématiques à son
époque et les balbutiements du
logarithme été inventée mais y'a plus
calculer un ratio qui permettait de
diviser leur quota 20-12 de mythos ego
et grâce à jean sébastien bach qui le
populariser au xviiie siècle
mais aujourd'hui tous les instruments
que vous entendez la musique que vous
entendez est régie par le calcul
mathématique de mathématiques
donc on peut dire que l'évolution de la
musique qui ont été assez symbiotique
avec l'évolution des sciences
une fois qu'on a compris la musique de
cette façon alors l'envoyant comme une
science elle a pu revenir comme un
retour de balancier et nous donner des
outils très utiles dans la vie de tous
les jours
par exemple le diapason donc le diapason
ça sert à s'accorder ça crée une note
pur lorsqu'on l'a sera sur quelque chose
un son pur dans le fond je vous montre
et ça c'est utilisé par les musiciens et
ça a été inventé par un musicien
rapidement salle a été pris dans le
domaine de la médecine par exemple en à
coup mes tripes pour diagnostiquer
certaines sortes de surdité et aussi
dans le diagnostic est certaine sorte de
fracture
parce que comme on l'a vu le son se
propage dans un milieu donc si on frappe
le diapason et qu on le colle par
exemple sur le milieu qui nous broie ci
a des fractures à l'intérieur ça va
faire mal parce que ça va vibrer donc on
peut savoir qu'une fracture
alors ça c'est une application plus
premier qui nous provient la musique et
qui était pas nécessairement fait pour
la science mais qui a quand même été
utilisé dans cette façon application
numéro 2 le seuil de dribbles sur voilà
rien n'est pas juste trop il y en a
vraiment besoin on parle de faits de
blur pour ceux qui sont pas familiers
avec le nom c'est ce qui fait par
exemple quand vous marchez sur la rue et
vous entendez un camion qui se déplacent
ça fait c'est une manifestation de
l'effet doppler long l'histoire courte
ce que ça veut dire c'est que quand on
est face à une source sonore qui
approche on a l'impression que le son
est de plus en plus aiguë quand on est
dos une source au nom qui s'éloigne on
n'allait pas sûr que le son est de plus
en plus graves
à l'origine christian doppler théorisé
cet effet l'eau en parlant des astres
qui changeait de couleur
dépendamment si s'approcher aussi
s'éloigner mais c'est un scientifique du
nom de boys bâle hook a pitié soeur à
l'acoustique s'y inscrit par pythagore
et ses instruments de musique et comment
il a confirmé sa au monde des sons c'est
qu'ils ont mis des musiciens sur un
train de la ligne ultra qu'amsterdam
veiller en europe et c'est comme ça
qu'il l'a prouvé au monde des
scientifiques à l'aide de musiciens que
l'effet doppler s'appliquait aussi aux
ondes
osons donc finale et aux ondes
mécaniques clinton compliqué mais ce
phénomène le couple est au phénomène de
l'écho c'est ce qui est à la base des
radars des policiers et aussi les
échographies
donc c'est un peu grosse musique vous
fait voir votre bébé une autre
application de la musique dans le
domaine de la science et la
musicothérapie peut-être que vous êtes
familier avec le terme c'est d'utiliser
la musique pour donner des soins
est ce la musique on l'a vu c'est très
puissant dans le cerveau donc ça peut
créer des comportements et ça peut
permettre d'être comme une une sorte de
thérapie qui va de pair avec les outils
qu'on a déjà
par exemple dans
la santé mentale en dépression si on
fait ça très simplement c'est vraiment
très simple au niveau physiologique y
aura une diminution de la sérotonine et
de la dopamine deux hormones qui qui
amène le plaisir donc et aussi une
diminution de l'activité neuronale
la musique y avait beaucoup de recherche
qui était fait et ça permet une
augmentation de ces hormones l'a6 et la
musique que vous aimez beaucoup que vous
appréciez écouter aussi ça fait une
augmentation de toute l'information qui
se propage dans votre cerveau donc une
orientation de l'activité neuronale
alors ça peut venir vraiment compensé
émis de pair avec tous les outils qu'on
a déjà
ça peut être une très bonne manière
d'aider la science à s'améliorer
et ce n'est pas juste pour la dépression
par exemple pour l'anxiété et aussi pour
les effets physiques sur votre corps
par exemple si vous essayez de vous
relaxer et en 9% dormait écoutent de la
musique de la musique qui calme mais ça
ça ça sort pas de nulle part c'est la
musique qui a un effet sur votre cerveau
qui ont ensuite un effet sur votre corps
qui ralentit votre coeur qui vous permet
d'être plus relax
donc ça c'est aussi au contraire quand
vous voulez vous motiver et voulait
aller faire du sport ou bien vous avez
quelque chose d'important à faire on
écoute la musique motivante une craque
un peu ça ça vient faire un effet aussi
physique sur vous donc penser que ça
provient tout d'onde cdc des ondes qui
proviennent d'un objet d'une guitare qui
crée ça dans votre corps et dans votre
cerveau tous combien de vous dire ce
n'est qu'un très très très bref survol
de l'immense quantité lien qu'il ya
entre le monde des sciences et la
musique
non nous ne sommes pas bizarre il y en a
plein et c'est très intéressant de les
cèdres et c'est à ça et à la quantité de
scientifiques étaient musiciens et la
quantité de musiciens qui avaient des
propos très satisfait donc la prochaine
fois que vous allez écouter une chanson
qui va vous donner des frissons vous
mettre la larme à l'oeil penser que la
science que la musique c'est le pont
entre les arts et la science
merci pour
comme si